hello everyone and welcome to round 10
of the 2018 world rapid championship
actually started recording this video
already but I had the names written
differently so I had to start over but
luckily I caught up to it during the
first two minutes but yeah just
listening to the two the amazing
commentary of the official broadcast a
bipedal echo in the beginning meters
mischenko it's incredibly difficult to
decide which games to show even as they
are doing it real time it is it is such
an impossible task to cover all of the
games not only from the open section but
also from the women's section and by the
end of the day there are so many rounds
played that you would need a hyperbolic
time chamber to create like a hundred
videos per day of all the amazing games
that were played but I will be checking
up on your suggestions you so feel free
to use the hashtag suggestions so I and
I will try to cover as many games as
possible like I said this is a game from
round 10 Carlson had a pretty bad start
at the first day so this is the second
day we are going to discuss the results
of the second day and I will be showing
the standings after day two but I will
do do more videos about today too and
then we're gonna check it out here he
faces a Grand Master from Tajikistan
some rated some almost 2700 in rapid I
think it's around 26 80 but rapid
ratings are you know the addition is so
fast so not really relevant for example
Andrew tank is rated 20 to 80 or
something or 20 to 30 something and well
he's a very strong Grandmaster so
doesn't doesn't really matter but
without further ado let's get straight
into the game Carlson has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 and the g6 we
have a knight BTW - sorry about that
and Bishop to g7 efore and d6
Bishop to b5 check c6 kicking the bishop
back with Bishop to d3 and now castles
and there was a one game in the database
where this position has been reached
also from 2018 Donal dubov played e5
here that game ended in a draw but here
some places a king-size castle and here
we have all ready for move seven a
completely new game and okay black
continues developing we have Queen to c7
preparing maybe to push a five at some
point rook to e1 and now definitely a
five calm c3 Carson keeps everything
together improves on his a very nice
Center and Knight B to d7 black now
continuous developing this night might
come to b6 at some point and well it
really depends on what white plays we
have a for preparing to meet Knight b6
with a five and b6 by black preventing
a5 while not preventing it a5 is still
possible but at least the black is ready
for it and you might also consider
developing your Bishop to b7 with night
to f1 by Carlson tree maneuvering night
this Knights to g3 now Bishop to b7 and
h3 we have rook F to e8 black continues
developing Knights the g3 and now a six
so black will be interested at pushing
v5 at some point in the future Bishop to
g5 are much more active Square for the
bishop and already if black decides to
push it away with h6 you will create
some targets black does go for h6 will
have Bishop back to d2 and now we have B
5 B 4 by Carlsen
and now you don't really have the option
of capturing on a 4 if you capture and
rook captures then they're really the
attack against the ace exponent will be
simply too overwhelming you will black
will either have to open up the position
with a 5 if you allow the pawn to stay
there then white will it will be very
easy to attack the pawn but it will be a
much better position for white so after
b4 of course you don't want to break the
tension
Knights to be six and now cross and
simply pushes it away we have a five and
nine go back to the seller and black is
Mike can be very happy here as the the
Queen side is now completely closed and
now black can focus on the center and on
the Kings side
Queen to c1 as by playing h6 black
created a target to cross and now
attacks it so King to h7 defending the
h6 pawn and now comes c4 as the Queen
also for the further supports the c4
pawn
rook a to c8 black now sort of finishes
development but still it's not very
clear what black will do about this
Bishop on b7 until this bishop is
activated it's like it's not even there
at some point you will play C 5 so
there's the possibility of activating it
that way but that's time still has not
come so first D captures on e5 and here
black misses the opportunity as white
controls more space it's a general
principle in chess if your opponent
controls more space you don't want to
you don't want to trade it down and
relieve the tension the pressure on your
own pieces and here perhaps capturing
with the knight would have been better
Knight captures pawn captures and black
might be able to go rogue d8 and then
perhaps bring the bishop into the game
but here black played D captures on e5
perhaps a bit over too optimistic
because now comes the Bishop to e3 and
Bishop to e3 is a very nice move by
Crossan as you can see the only open
file on the board is the D file and the
black will not really be able to use it
if Rudy 8 then still you're not going to
be able to use it if the knight doesn't
move from d7 and that's why it was
perhaps a bit better to exchange this
Knight if you move the knight then this
Bishop is coming to b6 and you will not
be controlling the D file but there was
one possibility to do it Knight to f8 is
a very nice move it does a leaf control
of the b6 square but then after Bishop
to b6 you can go Queen to d6 and now you
can still kind of control the D file a
bit we are Luke to e7 and rook to d7
how about okay mr. Faruk communitive has
a different plan
rook we have Queen to b8 getting the
Queen out of any attacks by Bishop to b6
with rook to d1 by Carlsen and now comes
Knight to f8 Bishop to b6 controlling
the d6 square we have night six to d7
and now comes c5 so now this Bishop is
not the greatest of pieces but it
actually is as it still controls the the
D eight square which is the very
important square and you don't ever want
to capture this if you play Knight
captures a captures then why
already has a passed pawn on d6 it's a
protected passport and well black will
never be able to trade down go into an
endgame with white having a passport on
b6 and also it's a very hard for black
to actually activate any pieces but okay
after c5 with Knight to e6 and now comes
the ship it back to b1 the rook is now
controlling the D file for the moment
but also the bishop at least the
third-ranked cousin is preparing a very
nice rock lifted by rook to a3 so
Knights to d4 now as the the night on d7
was under attack the knight now blocks
the rook rook to a3
now if Knight captures then the rook can
also capture on f3 Knight back to f8 and
now comes Knight captures on d4 not
allowing this Knight further protect the
d4 square with Knight to e6e capture
some before and now comes f4 and now
while you can go 96 with E 5 this night
isn't really going anywhere and it's
very hard to imagine that black will be
able to develop anything the rook can
never move the Queen doesn't really have
anywhere to go not the d5 has been
played you're no longer pressuring the
f4 square black black is lost here so
after f4 we look to e7 by black now
comes c5 and here comes Luke CT 8 so now
black couldn't really do anything along
the D file but has managed to double
rooks along the along the e-file and
perhaps if you can create some sort of a
blockade here maybe push f6 then maybe
maybe just maybe your position can can
be playable here we have Knight to e4 by
Carlsen and here comes Knight to e6 it's
yeah there's a really no way to go about
this position you have to make room for
the rook if you play something like f5
and a la Knight to d6 your look is
trapped the bishop is controlling d8 the
knight is controlling the entire eighth
rank so you do have to make some room
for the rook so nice to e6 but now comes
nice to d6 attacking the rook and here
the problem is if you go rook F 8 then
rook F 1 is coming this rook is coming
to f3 white will push r5 and black
cannot move any pieces the
okay the bishop can move back and forth
but that's not really relevant here the
Queen doesn't have anywhere to go you
can't use any of the squares for your
rooks and the white will simply slowly
but surely increase the position and
then in the end win by playing anything
White's position in plays itself
basically so after Knight to d6 we have
Knight captures an F for black decides
to give up a night for three pawns but
it's not not quite what it seems
Carlson plays Queen captures on f4 we
have Bishop captures on e5 attacking
Carlson's Queen Queen qf - not worrying
about any tactics because there are none
so it's actually okay to put your queen
and the same diagonal as the King Bishop
capture some b6c capture some d6 and
this is the problem here his opponent
thought that perhaps he could capture
here but there there is no better move
your look is under attack and if you
move the rook anywhere along the e-file
then Queen captures on f7 will win the
game and there are no others worse for
the road the only square for the rook
the rook is not lost is d7 but after
rook to d7 pretty much anything wins for
white let's say you go look to f3 attack
the pawn and after King g7 defending and
then you can simply sacrifice the bishop
here Bishop captures and after F
captures you will go Bishop captures on
d4 and now it's it's a forced checkmate
in six but whatever black plays let's
say King g8 then now you get to Queen -
a - check and after King to h7 you will
get rook to f7 check King will move now
comes rope to e7 check and after King f8
you will get Bishop to g7 checkmate
so how are the different ways for blacks
to lose this so black tried putting a
force on d6
but now across and just played Queen to
Bishop to c5 and now you already give up
a piece for some points but now you are
also losing the exchange here and this
will not be playable so in this position
Faro Camelot of resigned the game once
you move the Queen let's say Queen c7
you will play Bishop captures and after
Queen captures you wink wink after some
before and you're just down a hole rook
so it's very interesting how Carlsen
played out this entire game by forcing
this
basically to pretend to be a pawn for
the rest of the game but yeah I very
much needed win for the world's champion
in this 10th round of the 2018 rapid
championship like I said we're gonna
cover some more games after I show you
this game so we're gonna check out the
results after round 10 in that video I'm
probably gonna be uploading it right
after this one of course after I make it
but yeah quite an interesting him and
there were so many interesting games I
already have a couple of them that I I'm
planning to show but feel free to use
hashtag suggestions I also saw her
suggestions from yesterday so I will try
to at some point because it's a first
day of the rapid second day then third
days a third day of the rapid than two
days of blitz so it's very hard to find
the actual time to you know do it as I
also very much enjoy watching the live
broadcast but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Drupada Marius liftin doll Gabriel
Sanchez
Alicia Rafi and Thanos for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with some more interesting
content from the 2018 world rapid
championship thank you all and I will
see you soon